Jared Leto has had an interesting career,
to say the least.
He's found massive success as both a singer
and actor, including taking home an Oscar
for his work in Dallas Buyers Club.
He has sold millions of albums as the frontman
for 30 Seconds to Mars.
He also kind of, maybe, allegedly started
a cult that holds summer camps for devotees.
Allegedly.
Through all of this, Leto has attained a larger-than-life
status, and it's only been bolstered by some
of the interesting stories about him from
behind the scenes.
Most notably, the actor made headlines while
filming Suicide Squad for getting a little
too into his role as the Joker.
According to reports from several outlets,
not only did he send a dead pig to his fellow
cast members, but he also requested everyone
in the cast and crew refer to him as Mistah
J.
It's safe to say it was method acting taken
to extreme, and it's all the more bizarre
considering the fact that the Joker doesn't
do anything like sending pigs to anyone in
Suicide Squad.
Still, it earned the film a ton of publicity,
so it would make sense if he were to carry
over that technique into a similar role — namely,
that of suspected killer Albert Sparma in
the neo-noir thriller The Little Things, which
just debuted in theaters and on HBO Max.
Co-star Denzel Washington has said Leto was
on much better behavior during this production.
The Little Things stars a trio of Academy
Award winners, with Washington, Leto, and
Rami Malek all onboard.
The gritty thriller follows two cops from
different California counties who are on the
hunt for a serial killer.
Leto plays the suspected murderer, and while
this role could have allowed him to let his
method acting ways come into the picture yet
again, Washington said there were no such
shenanigans in an interview with USA Today.
When the subject of Leto's previous stunts
came up, Washington shut it down, but also
indicated the bizarre behavior would have
stopped quickly had it appeared.
He said,
"He didn't do any of that with me [...] He'd
have been paid a visit.
That wouldn't happen."
Apologies to everyone who was hoping for some
on-set fireworks.
On the contrary, Washington seems to have
had a great time working on The Little Things,
and had nothing but kind things to say about
working with both Leto and Malek.
He said:
"There's a whole crop of these younger actors,
and it's fascinating to watch them coming
up behind me [...] Jared is one, obviously,
and Rami is doing great work.
It's inspiring and like a wake-up call.
It's like, I have to get my act together here.
These guys ain't playing."
"You already felt me up, you're armed, I'm
not.
What are you so scared of, little boy?"
Washington doesn't seem to mind passing the
torch, so to speak.
In fact, he even paid to send the late Chadwick
Boseman to the University of Oxford theater
program in the '90s.
It proved to be an investment very much worth
making.
When it comes to adoration for one's co-stars,
it went both ways on the set of The Little
Things.
In an interview with Variety's Awards Circuit
Podcast, Leto revealed he was hesitant to
join the cast of this movie because he had
already played several characters with similar
psychology.
But when given the chance to work with this
kind of talent, he just couldn't say no.
He said:
"I'm with Denzel Washington and Rami Malek
and [writer-director] John Lee Hancock; I
thought, 'How can I not be a part of this
incredible opportunity?'
And I'm really glad that I did.
Because it was, it was an absolute adventure."
Leto's certainly no stranger to the industry,
but even seasoned veterans get starstruck
once in a while, and there was plenty of intimidation
to go around on the set of The Little Things.
Leto explained:
"If he walked in the room, it's still 'Denzel
Washington' to me.
It's not like, 'Hey, what's up Denzel.'
[...] I just have a lot of respect for him.
It's not easy to do what he's done.
And what he's done is he's been great in every
single movie he's ever made."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.